also nochmal euch alle da draußen dies
jetzt vielleicht noch nicht verstanden
haben
das outing war fake ja geil geil
wow ich habe vor einiger zeit hier von
einem youtube kanal hochgeladen in dem
ich auf ein video wo regiert habe und
zwar auf das video in dem er zusammen
mit piquet vor der kamera saß und so tat
als wäre sein ursprünglicher freund aus
dem ersten auto video nicht ein
wirklicher freund sondern eddie kaye wer
sein neuer freund und in diesem video
habe ich gesagt dass
höchstwahrscheinlich diese ganze
geschichte also auch sein ursprüngliches
outing fake ist also das mega pablo
nicht schwul ist auf dieses video mich
damals sehr negative reaktion bekommen
ich habe für meinen kanal relativ viele
des lecks bekommen und sehr viele leute
in die kommentare geschrieben hey
sebastian ich glaube du hast die ganze
sache nicht verstanden mit mega pablo
ist wirklich schwul und nur dieses video
mit ewig elverfeld und ja du hast nicht
kapiert turns out
ich hatte es doch kopiert halo hat die
komplette sache inklusive des
ursprünglichen outings gefegt heute ist
er einfach ist die erste er hat gestern
ein video hochgeladen mit dem namen mein
auto war fake und wir werden jetzt mal
anschauen und unsere meinung dazu
abgeben
ich bin unschuldig und zwar dieses video
ich muss dieses video machen ich weiß
viele sind verwirrt einige werden jetzt
so anbau ich hatte recht
also ich würde das nicht zu machen so
als wäre auch bauwerk mehr also hatte
wollte hatte recht und ihr anwalt
mitgeteilt sich dieses video gehabt
das ist nicht meine intention aber meine
intention ist mir die ganze sache mal
anzuschauen und das vielleicht auch für
die worte zu machen die damals meinten
ich hätte vorschnell geurteilt
ich bin damals als ich gesagt habe ich
glaube sogar sein eigentliches outing
ist fake einfach so müssen nach meinem
bauchgefühl gegangen wisst ihr ich hatte
einfach das gefühl ich meine es ist am
ende immer noch megawatt das sage ich
nicht um ihn zu beleidigen oder so das
will ich wirklich nicht aber dann kann
halt so was mal passieren denke ich mal
also vor eineinhalb monaten habe ich
mich geoutet
das video hat fast jeder gesehen es hat
1,4 millionen klicks es war platz
einzelnen trends und viele haben gesagt
okay das ist krank dass das fake also
ich weiss nicht also jetzt im nachhinein
ist man immer schlauer leuten ist klar
aber wenn wir mal drüber nachdenken
hätte man das wirklich ernsthaft
erwartet von mega pablo dass er aus der
versenkung zurück kommt gerade nach
seiner vorgeschichte dass er schon so
mental health institutionen war also das
ist wirklich geistig nicht gut ging
das ist nach dieser vorgeschichte zurück
kommt und ein outing video das von ihm
kommt tatsächlich echt ist also nicht
aus geistiger verwirrung und nicht aus
absicht entstanden ist eigentlich hätte
man das von vornherein wissen müssen und
ich sag's euch jetzt wie es ist sacha
und ich wir haben aufnahmen gemacht
bevor wir das gepostet haben uns ist
gerade irgendwie so ein haft gekommen
lass mal gucken wie die leute reagieren
würden
ja das ist immer gut leitet das ist
immer gut ganz ganz klassische alter
trick wenn man irgendwie mist baut und
weiß eine aktion die man gerade plan
könnte schiefgehen einfach bevor man die
aktion veröffentlicht noch mal so eine
weil sie eine rettungsweste in form von
einem video aufnehmen so ja also das ist
jetzt wirklich nur ein experiment an der
stelle keine upgrades bomben prank ja
also leute ich werde jetzt heute so tun
als würde ich zivilisten in der
innenstadt mit einer bombe hochjagen das
ist wirklich nur ein experiment um zu
gucken wie deutschland reagiert und
zugucken wie tolerant dieses land
gegenüber explosiven sprengstoff ist wie
die leute reagieren würden wenn ich mich
outen würde
wir wollen einfach nur klarstellen das
ist absolut nicht schlimm ist wenn man
schwul ist ja geil geil
wow liebe liebe schwulen liebe lgbt
community in deutschland seid ihr nicht
froh dass wir so jemanden wie michael
pablo haben also wo wir werden wobei
eine schule in deutschland wenn es nicht
so leute wie mir pablo geben würde
die einfach keine kosten und mühen
scheuen um sicherzustellen dass schwule
in deutschland akzeptiert werden mega
super wir haben versucht so ein
experiment heraus zu machen und wir
wollten das paar tage danach auflösen
wer alles optimal gelaufen ich habe
sozusagen gesagt keiner wird das selten
alle werden sagen weil ich dachte
deutschlands mega tolerant die sache ist
auch deutschland ist eigentlich mega
tolerant und den großteil von den leuten
in deutschland die wissen was im kopf
haben werden zumindest sagen okay ich
selbst bin nicht schwul und ich finde
dass vielleicht auch gar nicht mal so
gut wenn andere schwul sind aber ich
habe genug verstand im kopf um eine
klappe zu halten so wenn jemand anders
auf männer steht wenn man auf männer
steht eine frau frauen stellt und es mir
nicht gefällt weiß ich trotzdem ich bin
reif genug dass ich den nicht sagen muss
dass ich scheiße findet oder sie
beleidige dass bei miguel plus community
die wahrscheinlichkeit aber ein bisschen
höher ist dass die diese geistige reife
vielleicht nicht haben waren ja auch von
anfang an klar
im scheinbar nicht ich war schockiert
dass so viele so viele dass cages haben
klar einige am skate weil ich es bin ich
habe schon oft polarisiert und echt
scheiße gebaut aber als gab leider viel
zu viele die gesagt haben war schwul
ich guck dich nicht mehr uns so das ging
nicht in meinen kopf aber ich glaube das
ist einfach seine community leute also
ich meine mega pablo ist auch ein
spezieller typ müssen wir ehrlich
miteinander sein also müssen uns nichts
vormachen vor allem wenn jemand mega
pablo zuschauer ist und hardcore wiget
zuschauer fan ist sozusagen dann wird
diese person vielleicht ein bisschen
anders denken als die meisten auf
youtube und dann kannst du auch sein
dass in der wg pablo community der ein
oder andere 13 jährige max aus hannover
ist für den oft weit die größte
erfindung der menschheit ist und der
spur sein eben nicht so cool findet ich
dachte wie können neu zu denken ich
selbst habe auch so gedacht okay
schwulsein es vielleicht komisch oder so
und erst dann habe ich gecheckt alter
mann
was bitte wer sich selbst aber auch so
gedacht so saal ist voll komisch so ja
also ich habe das hier alles für die
schwule community deutschland gemacht um
zu zeigen dass wie es ist wenn man sich
outet ja ich selbst habe halt gedacht
dass schwulsein voll komisch ist
das ist für eine aussage was daran
komisch alter jedenfalls ich erzähle
euch jetzt wie es ist
wir haben das experiment verkaufen
wollen ich hatte diese idee nicht vor
kurzem nicht erst im dezember ich hatte
die chance zwei jahre lang zwei jahre
habe ich gedacht irgendwann out ich mich
löst das dann auch so soll sich aber
vorstellen also lasst uns diesen satz
mal wirklich vor augen halten er hat
zwei jahre lang auf dieser idee rom
gedacht dass er so tun möchte als wäre
schule und sich outen möchte bloß zwei
jahre lang überlegt dass du das machen
willst und die es in zwei jahren nicht
einmal die idee gekommen
es sei dumm ist und natürlich leute ich
würde lügen wenn ich jetzt nicht sagen
würde ich habe mich an die klicks gesagt
natürlich ich wusste dass das werde
macht ich wusste dass wir darüber reden
wird ich muss dass ich damit wieder
polarisiere jedenfalls wollten wir es
dann als jedenfalls war es mir egal und
leute ich wusste dass das klicks bringen
würde und ich wusste auch dass ich das
im dezember hochladen werde wo ich noch
mal mehr damit verdienen werde
das war krass als ich bin mal gespannt
wie er sich aus der schläger wieder
rausziehen will er hat quasi mit der
offenheit und der
unterstützungsbereitschaft der youtube
community gespielt aus welchem grund
noch mal weil dezember und man kann ein
paar mehr an verdiente jedenfalls
wollten wir es dann als experiment dann
auch auflösen und ab dann war es täglich
von uns dafür entschuldige ich mich
menschen machen fehler das rechtfertigt
das nicht ich scheiße war fehler von mir
ja okay also wir können es glaube ich
schon darauf einigen dass allein auch
schon die idee zu so zu tun als wäre man
schwulen outing video zu machen als
experiment sehr seltsam ist aber wie das
ganze abgelaufen ist das scheinbar so
dass er gemerkt hat moment mal das geht
ja richtig ab ich mache eine million
klicks auf das video und gerede darüber
sehr viele andere youtuber in
deutschland reden drüber
ja ja lass das lieber noch ein bisschen
weiter ausreizen also nochmal alle da
draußen dies jetzt vielleicht noch nicht
verstanden haben das outing war fake wir
wollten das experiment durchziehen und
am ende hätten wir sogar gutes resultat
gehabt und den leuten gezeigt dass
solche
da ist so tolerant ist weil wir mega
viele spa nachrichten bekommen haben vom
kleinen kindern die sagen du [ __ ]
da muss man wirklich an der stelle mal
kürzlich im moment nehmen auch ihr
zuhause einfach mal kurz eine runde
klatschen für mega pablo wirklich ist
wirklich so bisschen schlauer
es ist ein smart move pass auf ich lad
morgen ein video hoch leute ja ich habe
von meinem arzt die nachricht bekommen
ich leide an als tödlichen krankheit ich
habe krebs ja und dann in drei wochen
beim video übrigens das ganze war fake
das war nur um zu zeigen wie tolerant
deutschland gegenüber menschen ist die
tödlich krank sind
egal und wir haben so eine dokumentation
gemacht seine experimente form einer
dokumentation und haben es dann in den
länge gezogen und haben uns alle portale
gefilmt unserer erfahrung gesammelt ja
danke mir geht also gut von dir muss ich
wirklich sagen gut von dir also wir
haben in deutschland einfach nicht genug
professoren doktoren und
wissenschaftliche mitarbeiter an
universitäten die sich mit diesem thema
beschäftigen nein dafür hat es in diesem
fall einen kanal um 20 jährigen youtuber
mit pinkem halstuch und orangen pan
gebraucht danke für diesen beitrag media
blog ich wollte das auflösen mit dieser
dokumentation und dann habe ich mit
sascha darüber geredet und gesagt nein
wir können uns sich als die guten
verkaufen die jetzt selbstbewusst das
experiment anderthalb monate gemacht
haben könnt ihr auch nicht länger die
ganze kacke so absurd guck mal die ganze
pack ist so absurd dass einfach der
medien im hintergrund umfeld achtet man
darauf selbst dieser minion der wird von
keinem physischen objekt berührt denkt
sich bruder was für ein bullshit und
gibt einfach um können uns sich als die
guten verkaufen die jetzt selbstbewusst
das experiment einer zeit monat
zugemacht haben wir haben die leute
angelogen zu lange das ist kein
experiment mehr wir haben zu lange
gemacht wir müssen uns unsere schuld
eingestehen wir müssen sagen wir haben
fehler gemacht ich bin mensch leute ich
mache fehler
also ich finde ganz ehrlich wir als
youtube community so sollten schon in
den meisten situationen leuten auch eine
zweite chance geben
aber das ist wirklich einfach so 30
finde nicht dass man am ende einfach
sagen kann so
münchen machen fehler tut mir leid dass
ich so getan habe als wenn ich bei einem
verkehrsunfall und gekommen menschen
machen fehler
meine leute leider mache ich vielleicht
zu oft fehler ich mache zu oft sachen
über die ich nicht nachdenkt ich habe
ein jacky ickx gewartet ich habe sachen
gemacht die man nicht macht jetzt kommt
dann war so trocken
ja ich mache fehler ich habe ich habe
ein chicken wings gebadet last lasst uns
jetzt einfach mal so stehen wir kurz
fünf minuten und denkt mal darüber nach
das ist für mich so es ist wie ein
verkehrsunfall
man will eigentlich nicht hinschauen
aber man schaut trotzdem hinten und ich
muss dafür geradestehen ich will mich
nicht immer raus reden und gut reden
leute nein ich bin vielleicht nicht der
beste mensch und ich mache fehler
leute ich will mich nicht rausreden aber
jeder mensch macht fehler
ich habe einfach gerade mal meine
community und fast ganz youtube
deutschland komplett verarscht und habe
deren toleranz gegenüber schwulen
ausgenutzt um ein bisschen
aufmerksamkeit zu generieren und ein
paar klicks und dezember zu machen aber
jeder mensch macht fehler ich mich nicht
rausreden aber jeden cannes vergeben
werden ich bin sehr christlich
aufgewachsen wenn ihr mal scheiße baut
alkohol trinkt oder hat jemand anlügt
ihr könnt immer umkehren ihr könnt immer
dort um vergebung bitten müssen wissen
wir jetzt auch noch religionen diese
diskussion mit reinbringen hat das hat
es nicht schon gereicht wir stecken wir
wirklich schon tief genug drin in der
scheiße hier kennt darum geht es jetzt
gerade nicht es geht darum dass ich
einen fehler gemacht habe und also ich
will mich entschuldigen ich muss mich
entschuldigen ich kann mich nicht mehr
als opfer entschuldigen ja jetzt nicht
mehr aber so ver anfangen hättest du
einfach mal nachdenken können also ich
verstehe ich wie die ganzen sachen
zusammen passen er selbst sagt er findet
schwulsein komisch wollte aber dann
wiederum ein experiment machen und zu
zeigen dass schwulsein in deutschland
akzeptiert ist
es macht von vorne bis hinten keinen
sinn und mit diesem video
willst du genau das machen was du sagst
dass es nicht machen will ist nämlich
deinen namen wieder reinwaschen
aber ich glaube das wird in dem fall
nicht funktionieren wir haben da unsere
freunde gefilmt interviewt was sie sagen
was deren erfahrung war ja ich will euch
auch irgendwie wissen abwechslungsreiche
reaktionen auf dieses video bieten aber
es ist wirklich so alle zehn sekunden
stockmann und muss sich kurz wegdrehen
und kurz mal verschnaufen also wir
fassen zusammen
du hast eine dokumentation gemacht ok du
verwendest du worte wie dokumentationen
experiment so als wäre das irgendwie
eine legitime sache eine richtige sache
die du ja gerade gemacht hast
zusammenfassung für dich ist es nicht
aber er hat seine freunde gefragt und
hat ihr gesagt komm ich tue jetzt so als
wäre ich wohl was ist deine meinung dazu
hat keiner von denen die gesagt lasst es
aber ich will mich nicht als gute an
dieser situation darstellen weil ich
dass ich bin leute ich will mich nicht
als guter darstellen aber jeder mensch
macht fehler
ok also ich halt ein paar mehr als die
anderen ich habe fehler gemacht und ich
sehe ist ein
und ich will jetzt den geraden ehrlichen
weg gehen gebt mir geht mir noch eine
chance oder lass ich verlange nicht dass
ihrem ich verstehe mich jetzt lügt oder
pro du hast das einfach mit absicht
gemacht du wusstest genau das macht sagt
er selbstbewusst ist dass die ganze
sache polarisiert bewusst ist genau was
du machst welche konsequenzen das haben
wird hast das über eineinhalb monate
durchgezogen obwohl du wusstest dass es
nicht machen sollte sogar in dem moment
jetzt am ende kann man dann einfach
sagen jeder mensch macht fehler und
morgen kommt neu auf hold ich finde wie
auf youtube sollte uns mal ausführlich
gedanken darum machen wie man mit sowas
umgeht eure meinung dazu gerne morgen in
die kommentare aber das war wirklich
einfach dreist dumm
sehr frech allen gegenüber die wirklich
darüber nachdenken sich zu outen und
probleme mit ihrer sexualität haben und
ich finde das sollte nicht einmal so
eine konsequenz weiterhelfen
vorgeschlagenes wiederum könnte man kann
aber nicht in der schule raus und
bleib dran für mein video in zwei tagen
in dem ich so tun als hätte ich meinen
beinen bei einem skiunfall verloren